and I think who you watch a movie to in
a theater with plays a big role because
I remember we watched a film and the
only other person in the theater you
know that night was a celebrity and I
won't say who it was but they were there
to support the filmmaker and that person
was laughing and I found myself laughing
and then I'm like wait a minute
am i just trying to like join in with
this person is that the reason I'm loved
but it was a great experience and it was
surreal being in this huge theatre with
the one famous person watching this film
was it Quentin Tarantino it was not but
I can say that because I have seen
through a movie of mine actually it
wasn't supposed to be funny but he had
such a good time I don't know if that's
a good thing or a bad thing but he was
laughing from the first to the last
minute mmm and you could tell that the
rest of the audience was confused
because it he has a very succinct laugh
you can tell it's Tarantino you know so
if he thinks it's funny then they
probably were wondering should I think
it's funny and there was kind of this a
weird energy throughout the movie was
really interesting how that probably has
to do with it hype dynamic again with a
group dynamic that everyone there is
there is the desire to be on the same
page with your fellow human beings kind
of thing and I think that's why an
audience everyone in the audience is
kind of trying to have the same
experience and not be too far off from
the tribe kind of a thing and that's
maybe why comedies work so much better
with a big audience rather than with a
small audience because there's less
confusion it's like Oh everyone else is
having fun so I should have fun too and
then there's a the subconscious kind of
tendency towards them you never got an
answer as to why certain parts were
funny
due to the tarantino thing right and I
talked about to him afterwards and he
you know how he talked about all this
stuff but I don't think I got a word and
to ask what he thought was funny
hmm I know sometimes if we go to a
theater to watch a movie and it's
usually a mainstream film that's more
again sort of a bedroom community and
these aren't people in the industry and
what I'll do is I'll clap at the end to
see how many people clap because usually
within when you go to a Hollywood film
or something around this
people are all in the industry or they
know someone and they realize the hard
work that the people behind the scenes
put in they'll clap and I'm surprised
and sometimes David teases me how many
people don't clap right and they just
gather chairs groan and they were like
okay where do we go get cake and coffee
after this right and and I just find
that interesting is that is so dependent
on the area I have that with flights you
know how sometimes people clap after
plane lands we made it we made it and
when I first heard that maybe that's an
American thing because I think I was 35
years old when I first sat on a plane
where people are clapping and I was like
what did people expect are we
celebrating this outcome you know and
it's kind of the same with I think with
a movie that you expect the filmmakers
that have had a budget of millions of
dollars and the audience has just each
paid their good money to see that story
that they take it as a given that they
are being delivered a good time over
those two hours and that they feel like
they shouldn't have to celebrate that
they weren't screwed over and robbed of
their money you know so I can I can
understand the mindset of of not
clapping after a movie and I actually
have that when the movie was really good
I can't clap or worse even talk to
people afterwards like if you're really
affected by something it goes so far
you're in a different place you're not
clipping or like if you're clapping the
movie hasn't hundred-percent gotten you
maybe if it's a comedy that's a
different thing but if it's a large von
trier breaking the waves afterwards if
that got you you would not clap you know
because clapping means you are aware
exactly what you were saying aware of
the work that has been done right but if
the work has been done brilliantly
you're not even aware of the work that
has been done you were just flattened by
the story and by the characters that you
just experienced you don't think about
directors writers emmitt ographers
stuntmen all that stuff behind the
scenes because you're so impressed by
the narrative that you just experienced
I didn't know I felt that way about
clapping until we just talked about it
but that's maybe why I can understand
that people don't clap I don't know if
for one of my own movies I would rather
have people clap or not clap I know that
my first movie was this fake documentary
about suicide
no one ever clapped after that movie and
I would have been I would have known
that I had failed if they had clapped
after that movie you know whereas with
the other movies where it was more of an
upbeat ending ortley it's not that dark
it probably would have been okay for
people to clap which they didn't they're
either maybe I'm just making bad movies
I don't know what it is I don't
experience the club outside of festival
audiences you know I think at festivals
because people assume that want some of
the filmmakers out there there's the
polite kind of clear but I don't think
I've ever experienced it that an
audience was clapping after one of my
movies I mean interesting sort of survey
for artists that make films would you be
offended if someone clapped after your
movie or would you take it as a
compliment depends on the movie it
depends on the state you want to put
people into going back to finish or at
the end of seven but whether people are
clapping or not clapping and whether you
want that or not probably depends on the
story that you were just telling and the
emotion that you were hoping to put the
audience into Fincher could be just
because we had that example earlier for
seven you know you want the audience to
be so distressed and destroyed that he
probably wouldn't want anyone clapping
at the end of the movie I think he would
have known and a test screening that
something was wrong with this movie
whereas there are probably other movies
you know that are more upbeat and have a
different energy true and I am thinking
back to the ones that I have clapped out
recently and they were not sort of these
melancholy endings so yeah that does
make sense
you